are you having a bad day feeling blue
here's our guide to survive even the
worst day with the help from your
favorite movies oh no you overslept
start off on the right foot don't sleep
in now you've missed the bus
aw geez whoa whoa slow down
even if you woke up late or got pulled
over you know why I pulled you over
depends on how long you were following
me there's still time to turn your bad
day around I don't think you can eat a
good breakfast if you need a boost get
some coffee
a large black coffee put that coffee
down now your boss is being a chair you
hear any complaints when I do this and
the kids at school or mean scare off the
boy where's some carrot a bad pants make
for a bad day get some stretchy pants
sometimes you wear stretch
now you've got it look out yikes if all
else fails find ways to cheer up look at
these cute animals puppies so fluffy but
be careful about alligators I hate those
things get away from the misery go for a
run get some exercise try some yoga try
to smile face eat some cookies get some
sunshine try to sing your favorite song
have a bubble party
because bad days are like bubbles they
float away take it from an expert I
think that you just gotta have the bad
days so you can love the good days even
more trust me
I would know
you